you
I've always been fascinated with with a
marriage of music and drama
I worked for many years that in London I
played in bars and restaurants
everything else was a lot of theater and
eventually I was musical director for
Kent brana's ran his own theatre company
his first film came along here in the
fifth and I was asked to compose a score
so that's how the relationship with
Karen I began in film I was never
trained as a composer I suppose that my
root into it was a I was always hearing
music and I met someone who wanted to be
a film director when I was very young
and he was very young and I always
wanted to be a film composer so we
started making films together so to a
certain extent I suppose I learned on
the job you know I took piano lessons as
a kid but you know it was interesting
because as I got older I started liking
it less and less and less and all I
wanted to do was play Star Wars and I
you know remember the day that I told my
teacher look all I want to know is you
know and I said listen to this and I
just played plunked out the melody to
Star Wars I said you know that he goes
yeah and I said well I want to know
what's underneath that what makes that
work and he said oh you want to know
about theory it's like yes I want to
know about theory and he started
teaching me theory he started teaching
me chords and and from then on I was
like that's what I'm interested in the
creative process for composer can start
at any time ideally it's right at the
beginning ideally you would get the call
when someone's written a script and
they're thinking of making the film and
they're just casting and they talk to
you about ideas about character about
story about tone about the sort of music
that they might be thinking I mean I get
a call about a picture and the director
talks about it as my main starts to work
immediately that's that's the process
you can't help that if for example the
film has
on on-camera music and I'm required to
produce that compose that then obviously
I have to be there in pre-production and
then as the process of filmmaking
continues you know you can be involved
in you can go down to the set you can
see how the directors working with
actors you can go into the cutting room
you can see dailies and then you start
looking at assemblies and the ideas that
you've had and the things that you've
been working on you can apply them and
you can rework them and you can refine
them it's a constant ongoing thing
that's right deal with situation but
what equally can happen is that you get
a call saying we need this delivered in
two weeks time can you do it I tend to
work with the same people over and over
and over and I have a group of four or
five directors that I really love and
consider great friends and so we'll be
talking about these things a year or two
before anything happens the amount of
work that you have and the amount of
time that you have will match ultimately
you know I mean I've done films where
I've been given two or three weeks to do
the entire thing from start to finish
and I've managed to do it and it's taken
me two or three weeks I've done films
where I've been told I've got five
months to do it and it's taken me five
months to do it so I suppose the only
difference is in that five month period
there's probably going to be a bit of
procrastination at the front end and a
little bit of daytime telly watching and
Doritos eating I'm a very organised
composer I come in at the same time
every single day I come in between the
eight o clock and half past eight I
usually have a half an hour break and I
walk to anything from five to seven
depending on the schedule and I never
work Saturdays Sundays if I can help it
so I'm very very disciplined I like to
treat it sort of like it's my work and I
get up in the morning I get the kids off
to school and then I go upstairs to my
writing room and that's what I do and
I'm there till 5:30 and then I'm done
that's a time where I can kind of just
think about what I was working on or or
experience other things and maybe get
new inspirations or new new ideas I
think part of the thing about writing a
film which is got a lot of me
you know and it's not unusual now for
sort of big action films they have like
90 to 100 minutes of music yet
you know it's a lot of dots your first
couple of weeks when you're writing that
you kind of set the template for for
what it is that you're making and you
try and do something which feels a
little bit different each time but but
as you go further and further in you
realize that that's the language of the
film and to a certain extent it becomes
a little bit simpler the the later you
get into the process because you're not
going to try and do something completely
different a minute 85 then you've been
doing for the first eighty four minutes
but the big pressure when you're doing
those kinds of films with that amount of
music is just the amount you have to
churn out in a day you know anything
from sort of two to five minutes of
music sometimes you know and that's not
always the best way to be doing it it's
a little bit of a scramble but then when
you get to the theater and you watch the
thing and you realize that oh there are
loads of explosions or helicopters and
can't hear it anyway you know so that's
that's the other thing you have to think
about knowing when not to write you know
what has to adapt or die and see this -
- up-and-coming composers that you have
to be aware of what's out there you have
to ask and I work with younger people
who will challenge me and introduce with
new sounds and you can buy signs you can
you buy gear and and I have programmers
he'll twist sounds around and Jack Ryan
in particular and I spent four weeks
with a programmer creating new signs
before I even began you know I haven't
written out music since the last time I
that was Mission Possible 3 actually was
just at the last minute I decided I did
not like the love theme that I wrote and
I we were on the stage at Warner
Brothers and I just grabbed the piano
and wrote a new one there and I hand
wrote but that was kind of the last time
I think because the computer is now are
so fast and so convenient and you can
edit and change things it's so much
easier and it sort of eliminates a step
of communication between me and my team
you know I can then hand off a sketch
for the orchestra that is you know 75 80
% done
pretty much used computers from day one
the film now comes in digitally I sketch
a lot of things in in logic just on
Apple Macs but but then we move parts
into Sibelius and serve aliases the
prime sort of music part generating tool
when I did the Olympics we did quite a
lot of composition in Sibelius and you
can hear what you're doing and you can
see what you're doing and at that point
once we're happy with the music as it
stands it's always always now recall it
in Pro Tools you know the days of
getting a tape are long gone as I see to
two youngsters you can have all this
electronic knowledge but there will be a
limit to employment capabilities you
meet yourself more employable if you
have a thorough training in music if
that's possible and if you want to be
still working at 61 which I am so far
then you're pulling on all this
experience continually and certain
schools demand that kind of knowledge
but my job is to be sure I can do other
genres and I've been very fortunate I've
managed to write for every single genre
and if you stop tomorrow I would agree
have a good time
you